let's talk about the derek
shoving verdict guilty guilty
guilty
[Applause]
today we are able to breathe again
it was the outcome that so many in the
u.s had waited for
derek chovin the former police officer
who murdered george floyd by kneeling on
his neck
for 9 minutes and 29 seconds was found
guilty of murder and manslaughter
he now faces up to 75 years in prison
but can still appeal javin's lawyers
argued he followed police protocol
and that it was floyd's poor health that
led to his death
but prosecutors convinced the jury that
chauvin's use of excessive force
was plain to see that they breathe
pleased with the implication again
it was a murder in the full light of day
and ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
there are systemic reasons as a stain on
our nation's soul
ahead of the verdict there was a sense
of unease a fear that despite the
evidence
chauvin would walk free i was just
shocked i don't think anybody expected
this
i honestly thought that like another guy
was going to get away with something
that he should have never done in the
first place
and that worry was based on a long
history of police violence directed
against
black americans often with little or
even no accountability
why does that happen well here's how we
explained it last year
when george floyd's death galvanized
people across america
no justice not me
my black brothers and sisters are being
shot being killed
for no reason i am tired black americans
are a minority
just 13 of the population but in prison
they make up 33 of all the inmates and
if you're an unarmed black civilian
you're more than twice as likely as a
white person to be killed
and police violence against black
americans well that happens a lot
rodney king was unarmed when he was
beaten by la police and left with brain
damage
tamir rice was playing with a toy gun in
cleveland when he was shot by a police
officer 30 meters away
tamir was 12 when he died and brianna
taylor
shot nine times inside her own home in
louisville by police executing a search
warrant
it's like watching a bad movie over and
over again
and i think you hear that deep sense of
desperation
so why does it keep happening why do so
many black people feel that law
enforcement
and the justice system are failing them
let's look at the broken window theory
it was embraced by some police forces in
the 90s
and the idea is that if you crack down
on the small things you prevent bigger
crimes
now there are lots of studies that
question whether it actually works
but what we do know is that it's led to
more policing of poor neighborhoods
more police confrontations with
minorities more stopping
frisking and arrests of black people for
things like graffiti
petty theft and drugs i'm talking
white and black cops um and asian cops
dehumanize black people in poor areas
it's embedded in them that black people
are inherently bad
that doesn't start with police stations
it starts
with decades and decades of policies
that have created ghettos that have
created low-income communities
which require people to look for other
sources of income to support their
family which is why they have been in
the condition and that they're in
and then there's the practice of sending
officers to police communities they're
not from
the back of police officers in baltimore
live
far away some as far as pennsylvania the
first time they need a black person is
when
they get a badge and a license to take
their freedom
or their lives no one though is saying
policing isn't tough
the issue is that there's a line between
keeping officers safe
and the abuse of power they're often
trained to react quickly
maybe with force in a profession where
we can literally
have just seconds to survive we must
eliminate any obstacle that could get in
the way
of our reaction to an attack the rights
activists say
it can be hard to hold officers
accountable for lots of reasons
police departments often investigate
their own when there's a complaint
what if you did something wrong and if
your best friend at work
was the person that had to hand down the
punishment they probably wouldn't hand
down that severe
of a punishment right that's kind of how
these departments work
even if a case goes to trial the law
says use of force
must be judged from the perspective of a
reasonable officer
they all end up saying the same thing i
fear for my life like you hear this over
and over again
when you shot that guy eight times in in
the back you fed for your life
because he was running away from you
it's why so many black americans have
been using their phones
to keep a record of what happened
what we really want at the end of the
day is to feel safe in our communities
and to be protected
and so it is not a all cops are bad
there's a list of police officers that
are still off the hook
and that culture and policing is bad
in the case of derek chovin the jurors
decided unanimously that he was guilty
that's big and it's rare so what comes
next
some people especially among democrats
are calling for much more profound
change
a measure of justice isn't the same
as equal justice we still must
reform the system that's going to be
hard because the issues around police
brutality
gun violence and racial justice are
politically divisive in america
but while nothing gets done people are
still dying
earlier this month dante wright was
pulled over by police for a minor
traffic offense
and ended up dead the police officer who
shot him
said she confused her gun for a taser
hey and just minutes before the shoven
verdict
16 year old mikaya bryant was shot and
killed by police in ohio
get up get down get down
police body cam footage shows her
swinging at two other people with a
knife
according to the new york times more
than 60 people have died at the hands of
law enforcement
over the three weeks that javen's trial
lasted
more than half of them were people of
color this is not justice this is
accountability
of a very small part of the issues that
are happening here in the united states
of america
it is an incomplete verdict and it's
incomplete justice amanda gorman the
poet from president biden's inauguration
put it this way victory would be george
floyd
being alive every day black americans
worry
if they will be next is another day
without justice
[Music]
we on the start here team and our
colleagues across al jazeera are
following this story and issues around
gun violence and police reform
really closely we'll have more episodes
on those coming up
see you back here soon